[Music]
what's that belief nation happy weekend
this is a quick video because we need
your help
Nina and I like to often play a game
called would you rather this is Nina no
okay
listen there are some new viewers to the
channel we get 2,000 new subscribers
every single day and for those of you
who are new this is Nina
anyway so we like to play
would you rather game so we asked each
other would you rather questions fun way
to get to know your partner a little
more detail run some examples
would you rather fly or be invisible
superpowers would you rather lose all
your pictures or lose all your money
what else have we done
Nina's blankie man I'm blanking that too
but I came up with two she's too busy
playing with Teemo you got to focus
focus on belief nation we thought for
the next life with every video next
weekend we would answer your deep no
know what your would you rather
questions they would go I've got a net
so let us know what would you rather
questions you want us to answer and we
will pick
I don't know between 5 or 10 of them and
respond to them
in the next video put it down the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching hope you are happy face
this is why you don't multitask with
Teemo hope you guys have a great weekend
and whatever you have is like what
government see you we don't do a lot of
like food and then continue to believe
and whatever your one more days we'll
see you soon much love I will see you
soon bye